So what happens when an AI model grades its own homework?
I mean, for a long time, we just thought it would, you know, reinforce its own
hallucinations. Right, exactly.
But today we are actually looking at how models are learning to correct their own
confident errors and doing it without any human supervision at all.
Yeah. Welcome to today's Deep Dive. It is August 11th, 2026.
And for you, the AI builder, our mission today is to unpack five fresh updates
covering deployment infrastructure, unsupervised self-correction, and, well,
cooperative multi-agent systems.
Because, I mean, before a model can actually reason or correct itself, it has to
run somewhere, right? And deploying across wildly different hardware ecosystems has
historically been this, you know, massive bottleneck.
Oh, totally. But that friction is really starting to disappear.
Like, OpenAI's daybreak cybersecurity models are now live on AWS via Amazon
Bedrock. Which is huge, because if you are building enterprise security
workflows, those advanced capabilities are now sitting securely right next to
where your enterprise data already lives.
Exactly. And the local deployment side is seeing the exact same momentum.
I mean, Alama just rolled out version 0.3 to 0.8.
Right. So instead of developers constantly worrying about whether an agent like
Claude Code or, you know, a personal assistant like Hermes will even run on
a specific machine. This just bridges the gap.
Yeah, bringing muse glimmers across platforms.
So Apple silicon users get this massive MLX engine upgrade, allowing native image
input, while Nvidia and AMD users get seamless cross-platform support.
Let's unpack this a bit, because the real game changer for the AMD hardware side
is happening over in the llama.cpp ecosystem.
They just shifted to a new build system called The Rock.
Wait, The Rock?
Yeah, for build 103.56. Shifting to ROCM 7.14, it's basically like traveling
overseas. And instead of buying a new power plug for every single country,
llama.cpp just gave developers a master universal adapter.
Oh, I see. So you just build the package once and it natively fits into any Linux
environment. Exactly. Whether it's a dev, an RPM or a tarball, it works.
That sounds amazing. But I mean, the uncertainty for me here is just the
messy reality of developer environments.
A universal adapter sounds great.
But in a heavily fragmented real world system with weird dependencies, does a
multi-architecture deliverable actually hold up without breaking?
Yeah, that is the big question.
The real test will absolutely be the edge cases.
A unified package system drastically reduces boilerplate setup.
But, you know, you are still relying on the underlying hardware drivers to
behave predictably when pushed to their limits under heavy enterprise loads.
Right. But assuming that deployment infrastructure holds up, you eventually
have a running model. But what happens when that model inevitably makes a
mistake? Because historically, you'd need a human in the loop to fix it.
Not anymore. There is this new research on policy self-distillation, which
allows large language models to correct their own errors using internal
consistency. Wait, really?
Entirely without external supervision.
Yeah, completely. Instead of relying on a human curated data set for
external supervision, the model generates multiple pseudo solutions for a
single problem, checks them against each other and, well, uses a majority
vote to update its own policy.
OK, here is where it gets really interesting.
To me, this sounds exactly like a student taking a test, guessing the
answers five different ways and then grading themselves based on whichever
guess they wrote down the most.
That is a pretty great analogy, actually.
Right. But if the external ground truth is completely removed, couldn't
a model just be confidently wrong?
If its foundational logic is flawed, doesn't a majority vote just reinforce
the hallucination?
Well, that is the exact danger of closed system reasoning.
If the model starting premise is entirely off base, self-distillation just
creates an echo chamber.
So how do they fix that?
By forcing the mechanism to explore wildly different reasoning paths before
it actually votes. It is not just repeating the same answer, it is
actively debating itself from multiple angles.
Oh, wow. So if the consensus holds up after that internal debate, it is
statistically much more likely to be accurate.
Exactly. So we have models successfully debating text on a screen.
But, you know, if an LLM hallucinates, you get a bad line of code.
If a model navigating physical space makes a mistake, you get a car crash.
Yeah. Which brings us to CMU drive and V2V VLA.
This is a massive leap from text to the physical world.
It really is. V2V VLA stands for vehicle to vehicle vision language
action. Researchers have created a closed loop benchmark where multiple
connected autonomous vehicles use language models to jointly generate
actions, predict future waypoints, and communicate in safety critical
traffic scenarios.
I have to admit some confusion here.
How does a language model drive a car?
I mean, language is inherently slow and sequential.
You read one word after another.
Right. That's the intuitive roadblock.
Yeah. So how does that translate to split second physical safety when
another car abruptly slams on its brakes?
What is fascinating here is how the model compresses that process.
V2V VLA uses language as the underlying logic board to process what
it sees.
So it is not just parsing text step by step.
No, exactly. Instead of having one system for vision, a separate one for
deciding and another for steering, it processes the visual data, runs a
high speed logical deduction in the background, and outputs a physical
steering command and a communication signal to the other cars.
All in a single forward path.
Wow. So what does this all mean for you as a builder?
It provides the very first open source foundation and checkpoint for
end-to-end cooperative driving.
But the uncertainty remains like, can language-based reasoning dependably
scale to the sheer unpredictability of human background traffic in real
time?
Right. It completely redefines the level of autonomy we can expect from
these systems, both in the cloud and on the road.
Yeah. We started today looking at robust AWS and local deployment
pipelines, moved into models correcting their own homework through
internal debate, and landed on autonomous cars coordinating through
compressed language.
It's a wild time to be building right now.
Truly. Which leaves us with a final thought for you to ponder as you
get back to building today.
If models can self-correct via internal majority vote and autonomous
vehicles can jointly reason and talk to each other to navigate
traffic, what happens when these multi-agent systems develop
communication policies so efficient that human builders can no
longer decipher them?